Welcome to the presentation
on multiplying fractions.
Well, I think today you'll be
very happy because you'll find
out that this is one of the few
times where multiplying
something is easier than adding
it, I think, or subtracting
it for that matter.
And if you don't believe me,
let's do some problems.
Let's start with 1/2 times 1/2.
So when you multiply fractions
it's very straightforward.
It's essentially just two
separate multiplication
problems.
You multiply the numerators,
so you get 1 times 1.
And you multiply the
denominators, 2 times 2.
1 times 1 is 1.
2 times 2 is 4.
So 1/2 times 1/2
is equal to 1/4.
That makes sense.
That's like saying 1/2 of 1/2
is 1/4, which makes sense.
What if we had
negative numbers?
Well, if I had 1/2 times
negative 1/2 -- and when you
have a negative fraction it's
good ascribe the
negative number.
I tend to ascribe the negative
number to the numerator
-- negative 1 over 2.
You realize that negative
1/2 is the same thing
as negative 1 over 2.
Hopefully that make sense.
So 1/2 times negative 1/2,
that's just the same thing as 1
times negative 1 over 2 times
2, which equals negative 1
over 4, which is the same
thing as negative 1/4.
What if I had different
denominators, and when you're
adding and subtracting
fractions that tends to
make things difficult.
Well, it's not necessarily
the case here.
If I had 2/3 times 1/2, just
multiply the numerators, 2
times 1, and you multiply
that denominators 3 times 2.
So you get 2 times 1
is 2, 3 times 2 is 6.
And 2 over 6 we know from
equivalent fractions is
the same thing as 1/3.
That was an
interesting problem.
Let's do it again and I want to
show you a little trick here.
So, 2 over 3 times 1/2 -- as
we said, any multiplication
problem you just multiply the
numerators, multiply the
denominators and you
have your answer.
But sometimes there's a little
trick here where you can divide
the numerators and the
denominators by a number,
because you know that this is
going to be the same thing as 2
times 1 over 3 times 2.
Which is the same thing -- I'm
just switching the order on top
-- as 1 times 2 over 3 times 2.
All I did is I switched the
order on top, because you can
multiply in either direction.
And that's the same thing
as 1/3 times 2 over 2.
Well that's just is 1/3 times
1, which is equal to 1/3.
And why did I do that?
Well I want to show you that
these 2s, these 2s, all I did
is switch the order, but at
all times we had 1, 2 in the
numerator raider and I had
1, 2 in the denominator.
If I wanted to, and this is
kind of a trick for doing
multiplication really fast so
you don't have to reduce the
final fraction too much,
you get 2/3 times 1/3 --
2/3 times 1/2, sorry.
You say I have a 2 in the
numerator, 2 in the
denominator, let me divide them
both by 2, that equals 1/3.
Just a fast trick.
I hope I didn't confuse you.
Let's do a couple of more
problems, and I'll do
it both with the trick
and without the trick.
What if I had 3/7
times 2 over 5.
Well, multiply the
numerators, 3 times 2 is 6.
7 times 5 is 35.
That's it.
Let's do some negative numbers.
If I had negative 3 over 4
times 2 over 11, well, that's
negative 6 over 44, which
is the same thing as
negative 3 over 22.
And we could have done that
cross-dividing trick here.
Let's do it again
with the cross--.
Times 2 over 11.
We say oh, well 2 and 4,
they're both divisible by 2, so
let's divide them both by 2.
So 2 becomes 1, 4 becomes
2, and then our answer
becomes minus 3 over 22.
Negative 3 times
1 is minus is 3.
2 times 11 is 22.
Do another one right here.
If I had negative 2/5 times
minus 2/5, well, that just is
equal to negative 2 times
negative 2 is positive 4.
It's 5 times 5 is 25.
4 over 25.
And that's, just remember, a
negative times a negative is a
positive, which makes sense.
Let's just do a couple
more problems since we
have a lot of time.
But I think you probably
got this by now.
You're probably realizing that
multiplying fractions is a
lot easier than adding or
subtracting them, hopefully.
I guess it's not a bad thing if
you find adding or subtracting
fractions easy as well.
Let's do -- I'm just
making up numbers now
-- 2/9 times 18 over 2.
Well here we could, well, we
have a 2 in the numerator
and a 2 in the denominator.
Let's divide them both by
2, so they both become 1.
And we have an 18 in
the numerator and a 9
in the denominator.
Well they both are divisible
by 9, so let's divide
them both by 9.
So 9 becomes a 1, and
the 18 becomes a 2.
So you have 1 times 2 over 1
times 1, well, that just equals
2 over 1 which equals 2.
That was pretty
straightforward.
We could have done it, I guess
you could call it the hard
way, if we said 2 times 2
over 9 times 18 over 2.
2 times 18 is 36.
9 times 2 is 18.
And 36 divided by 18, and we
can see 18 goes into 36 two
times, that also equals 2.
Either way is fine.
If you don't feel comfortable
doing this trick right
now, you don't have to.
All that does is you won't end
up with huge numbers in your
product that you'll have to
figure out if they can
be reduced further.
Let's do two more problems.
Minus 5 over 7 times 1 over 3.
Minus 5 times 1 is minus 5.
7 over 3 is 21.
That's it.
Let me do one with the
little trick I showed you.
Say I had 15, and here I think
you'll see why that trick
is useful, over 21
times 14 over 5.
Well clearly, if we multiply
this out we end up with
pretty big numbers.
I think 220 one 105 and
you have to reduce those.
It becomes a big mess.
But we can see that 15 and
5 are both divisible by 5.
So let's divide them both by 5.
So 15 divided by 5 is 3.
5 divided by 5 is 1.
14 and 21, they're
both divisible by 7.
14 divided by 7 is 2.
21 divided by 7 is 3.
So we got 3 times 2 is 6 over 3
times 1 is 3, which equals 2.
That's the same thing
as what I said before.
If we had multiplied 15
times 14 that would
have been 210 I think.
Yeah, 15 times 14 is 210.
And 21 times 5 would have been
105, and you would have to say,
I guess in this case it's kind
of obvious, that 210 is 2 times
105 and you would have
gotten 2 as well.
So hopefully I didn't
confuse you too much
with that last problem.
But I hope you realize
multiplication's pretty
straightforward.
You just multiply the
numerators, you multiply the
denominators, and then if you
have to reduce you reduce, but
you're pretty much done.
I think you're ready now to try
the multiplication module,
and I hope you have fun.